[Música]
giran vía confinamiento a una de sus
principales regiones industriales medio
millón de personas están siendo
monitoreadas por un brote de kobe 19 la
provincia de zhejiang al mismo tiempo
que las autoridades confirmaron la
llegada de omicron a tianjin tenemos
informe desde beijing
crecen las tensiones entre eeuu y china
en su gira por la región indo pacífica
el secretario de estado de joe biden
llamó a beijing a detener acciones que
calificó de agresivas en respuesta china
acusó a su contraparte de fomentar las
divisiones e instigar a la confrontación
en la región
último debate de candidatos a la
presidencia en chile el izquierdista
gabriel boric y el ultraderechista josé
antonio kast suavizaron sus posturas
para buscar apoyo del centro de cara a
la segunda vuelta que se celebra este
domingo los aspirantes buscan capturar
los votos del centro y los indecisos
gracias por permanecer con nosotros
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 les habla daniel
hablando la comenzamos en china en donde
nuevamente el hobbit el levanta las
alertas de las autoridades al mismo
tiempo que el territorio continental
detectó el primer caso de omicron en
tianjin en la poderosa región industrial
de changing confinar ahora medio millón
de personas una vez que se detectaron
217 casos en apenas una semana
nuestro corresponsable en beijing a
adrián foncillas nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
más del medio millón de personas están
confinadas ya en la provincia de que ya
el epicentro del último rebrote de
coronavirus en china veis al 44 de los
51 casos detectados hoy en el país lo
que eleva el balance por ciento es la
presencia de jan situado en la costa
oriental es clave en la economía
nacional no sólo por su capacidad fabril
sino porque de ahí parten el grueso de
las exportaciones hacia del mundo el
último rebrote coincida más con la
temida llegada de la última variante
omicron a pesar de todo el blindaje que
impone en china son dos casos en los
últimos días el último se trata de un
hombre de 67 años que lleva del
extranjero y que como todos se había
tenido que someter a variados test antes
de volar y que tras aterrizar fue
confinado en un hotel durante dos
semanas donde volvía a dar negativo en
todos los test sólo dio positivo en su
tercera semana cuando ya cumplía la
cuarentena domiciliaria el caso revela
la dificultad de protegerse de la última
variante lo que hace pensar que china no
va a relajar las restricciones de
entrada ni va a jubilar su política de
'tolerancia cero' a pesar de contar ya
con más del 80 por ciento de la
población vacunada y en otras noticias
de la pandemia de eeuu superó el lunes
la marca de los 50 millones de contagios
por kobe de 19 de acuerdo con la
universidad johns hopkins
798 mil personas han muerto por
coronavirus en ese país la cifra se
alcanza cuando ya circula la variante
omicron más en el siguiente informe de
luís méndez
el 14 de diciembre de 2020 sandra
lindsay una enfermera de la ciudad de
nueva york fue la primera persona en
recibir una dosis de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 un año después lejos de haber
superado la crisis está se mantiene con
un número de contagios en aumento y que
ya supera los 50 millones ello llevó al
estado de nueva york a imponer nuevas
medidas
people
las personas que atienden en casa es una
situación pero cuando presionan a un
sistema de salud agotado y hablo por
cada persona que trabaja allí incluyendo
a los altos ejecutivos por casi dos años
cualquier cosa que podamos hacer para
ayudar a aliviar esa olla de presión es
una de mis prioridades
es formar genes parís en otros estados
los contagios y hospitalizaciones
mantienen el sistema de salud colapsado
y el número de pacientes por la
enfermedad empieza a generar tensiones
entre los trabajadores de la salud hoy
fue bastante difícil porque es mi
tercero esta semana lo siento en eeuu el
brote de ccoo y 19 ha causado la muerte
de 798 mil personas más que en ningún
otro país del mundo y con un promedio de
30.000 muertes diarias en el último mes
seguimos hablando de ese país pero esta
vez de las nuevas fricciones entre la
casa blanca y beijing el secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken está de
gira por la región indo pacífica para
profundizar sus alianzas durante su
primera visita a indonesia el
funcionario advirtió que eeuu sus
aliados y algunos reclamantes del mar de
china meridional
rechazarían cualquier acción ilegal por
parte del gobierno de singh ping que
reclama casi todo ese territorio como
suyo china por su parte considera la
postura de washington como una
interferencia que podría amenazar la
estabilidad regional
estamos decididos a garantizar la
libertad de navegación en el mar de
china meridional donde las acciones
agresivas de beijing amenazan el
movimiento de más de 3 billones de
dólares en comercio cada año
zhu jin joo los métodos de eeuu para
incitar a la división e instigar la
confrontación son impopulares en todo el
mundo y esto definitivamente no
funcionará en la región de asia y el
pacífico
y el presidente de filipinas o rodrigo
duterte declinó su candidatura al senado
en las elecciones generales de mayo de
2022 según el portavoz de la comisión
electoral la presidencia de seis años de
aductor que finaliza en julio de 2022 y
la constitución le impide aspirar a un
nuevo mandato el mandatario filipino
quien llegó a anunciar hace unos meses
que se retiraría definitivamente de la
política es investigado por la corte
penal internacional por supuestos
crímenes de lesa humanidad por la
sangrienta guerra contra las drogas que
él mismo a liderazgo
chain
y los comicios en chile- entran a su
recta final la noche del lunes los
candidatos se enfrentaron cara a cara en
el último debate previo a la segunda
vuelta de elecciones presidenciales de
este domingo 19 de diciembre los
discursos más moderados revelan como los
aspirantes buscan el centro para atraer
votos
en el último debate antes de las
elecciones el izquierdista gabriel boric
y el ultraderechista josé antonio kast
buscaron en el centro las protestas de
2019 y el actual proceso constituyente
marcaron el inicio
pregunta es quien generó esa violencia
extrema no fue la ciudadanía que tenía
legítimo derecho a manifestarse
muy radicales y nosotros nos oponíamos a
un acuerdo forzado por la violencia
extrema y yo tengo muy claro de que
ninguna posición se puede atrincherar en
un lugar en donde diga todo nada
los candidatos debatieron temas de
interés para los chilenos tanto sociales
como económicos moritz líder de la
coalición apruebo dignidad se distanció
de las propuestas más marchistas del
programa casas candidato del partido
republicano se alejó de opiniones
anteriores contrarias a los derechos el
eje ético más en el debate cruzado se
produjo el mayor enfrentamiento de la
noche espero espero que los chilenos
tengan claro que una persona que sólo
pide perdón cuando se le pilla en una
acción incorrecta puede tener otras
otros temas pendientes también yo creo
que la gente sabe en su casa las
caricaturas que ha instalado la campaña
del terror que ha instalado josé antonio
kast quizás la más sucia desde la época
de la dictadura la que usted apoyó y que
éste finalmente versión pinochetista de
piñera que representa sus antonio kast
es un peligro para el país y en
particular para la gente que más mal lo
está pasando finalmente en el minuto de
oro ambos candidatos y trataron de
convencer a su electorado decirles como
lo dije en el debate anterior que vienen
tiempos difíciles y que se requiere un
gobierno que dé estabilidad a un
gobierno que hable con la verdad un
gobierno que ejerza la prudencia y la
autoridad si por el contrario quieren un
cambio una transformación
en paz con orden estabilidad pero la
transformación profunda para que
tengamos mayor justicia y dignidad los
invito a hacerse parte de este proyecto
colectivo los expertos califican estos
comicios como los más inciertos en 30
años
y ya es oficial la ceremonia inaugural
de los juegos olímpicos de parís 2024
tendrá lugar en el río sena según
anunció el comité organizador será la
primera vez que esta ceremonia se
celebre fuera de un estadio olímpico se
espera que 600 mil espectadores puedan
ver la ceremonia muchos de ellos sin
pagar entrada
parís 2024 romperá la tradición y echará
abajo los muros de los estadios en 2017
mostró un adelanto de lo que vendrá
cuando una armada de aficionados
descendió al río sena anunciándose como
sede de los próximos juegos olímpicos el
26 de julio de 2000 24 10.000 atletas se
subirán a más de 160 embarcaciones para
una ceremonia de apertura al aire libre
nunca antes vista en mi mente hs del
dojo parís 2024 está intentando repensar
los juegos con un evento excepcional que
será el orgullo de francia la ceremonia
de apertura de representar esa ambición
por unos juegos diferentes creativos y
espectaculares para la gente y de sus
ideas normalmente la ceremonia de
apertura es vista por más de 1000
millones de personas en todo el mundo la
edición de parís contará con un público
presencial en torno a las 600 mil
personas en un recorrido de 6 kilómetros
a lo largo del río y de los principales
monumentos parisinos el espectáculo
contará con hologramas sobre el agua
bailarines en los tejados y espectáculos
aéreos quedan por anunciar las medidas
que aseguren un espectáculo de este
calibre y el lugar exacto donde se
ubicará la llama olímpica aunque hay una
opción bastante obvia una alta y
puntiaguda
con esto finalizamos nuestro informativo
los invitamos a que se queden con
nosotros
[Música]